[Musique]
techer emma agricultrice élu à la
chambre d'agriculture et président de la
vda association féminine pour le
développement agricole de la rime
[Musique]
agricultrice déjà c'est mon mari l'a
commencée et marc legrand dit à mes
enfants et puis quand les enfants la
rente à l'école m'a décidée 2ème marque
ce que les compliquer dans mon métier
d'agricultrice c'est que les
agriculteurs ils croient qu'on n'est pas
capable de 2 par exemple prendre la
pioche et khaled postes soit jaune y en
a vraiment marre et culture il vraiment
odieux quoi et puis les normales aussi
un kilt est pas un métier facile on a
obligé de faire nos preuves mais il faut
encore changer les mentalités
l'association féminine pour le
développement agricole de la réunion
parce que les femmes dans l'agriculture
les vrais qui n'est pas trop reconnu on
sait une équipe de jeunes nous vois
plein de choses pour l'avenir
la vente de produits nous réunit à nous
aussi parce que nous ne peut pas parle
que de l'agriculture si vous connais
comme ma femme pense pas que
d'agriculture pour changer un peu les
idées aussi
alors nous fait un travail de conseil
aussi auprès des agricultrices
là par exemple dont la russie la hausse
nous l'a trouvé six agricultrice qui
vont rentrer dans l'association
pour nous cette découverte parce que
nous connais pas du tout la production
s'il ose et puis tu vas apprendre aussi
les gens d'à peine des caf quoi et
plantes par exemple les agricultrices à
peine des quatre il avait cru triste du
côté de saint joseph il fait de cocu my
fait de la route ça ne nous connaît pas
donc c'est poussa n'a beaucoup des
changes dans l'association
l'association et met en place la halle
en train de mettre en place des marchés
de productrice vous prouver que nos
produits c'est donc il fait il ne
participa à fait tout ça
alors solidarité parce que il faut
donner aux agriculteurs les informations
c'est dans ma façon aussi collet m'a
gentiment voyage aux antilles - sol
idéal evry un n'aime pas voir les gens
dans de mauvaises situations
donc si muguet 3 une solution puzzle
n'essaye
tout le monde travaille ensemble parce
que ces désaveux que tu es travail mais
s'il faut la population ils consomment
ce que nous fait aussi bon courage à
nous travail est bonne a dit que le
produit local et qui a dépêché un et
puis c'est pour la sorte et aussi parce
que tout ce qui sort dehors là plein de
produits dessus les gens et nous réseau
timal me trouver là rien malheureusement
nous lançons une plaie de notre
tradition